[Musique]
c'est jean claude williams qui est avec
nous ce matin dans son caddie professeur
émérite de sciences politiques
observateurs de notre histoire
contemporaine et consulte aussi sur
notre chaîne dont jean-claude bonjour
maryse bonjour à toutes et à tous alors
février 2009 à février 2010 9 10e
anniversaire de cette mobilisation qui a
marqué notre histoire
avons nous raison jean claude de dire
qu'il s'agissait là de la plus grosse
mobilisation connu chez nous à qu'elles
étaient de ce fait historique
alors je ne sais pas s'il est historique
mais c'est une très forte mobilisation
évidemment pour être historique il
aurait fallu qu'elle produise des effets
en réalité on peut dire que pampelune
formule facile que la montagne a
accouché d'une souris très largement
ouais la jeunesse de ce mouvement
jean-claude l'agenaise c'est le prix du
carburant d'abord en guyane a tendance à
l'oublier ça bien sûr ça a commencé
comme cela
en guyane le ca s'est vite calmé les
fous rires et puis il ya une sorte de
relais qui a été pris en guadeloupe
devenir beaucoup plus construite
il faut dire que la situation des
syndicats en guadeloupe était très
différente de celle libellée la
martinique constitué dans ce qu'on
appelle le lkp lyannaj contre la
profitation
avec en plus une figure emblématique
celle d'elie domota et avec on ne dit
pas aussi et c'est un cahier de
doléances très complet précédé on ne dit
pas non plus à ses dunes d'un
avant-propos en quelque sorte en créole
et dans lequel sept à mon propos dans
lequel était précisé que finalement rien
de définitif ne sortirait c'est
finalement en lui était pas à bas le
capitalisme et le colonialisme et
lorsque les martiniquais ne pas que
l'islam c'est la vérité vont finalement
s'inscrire dans la foulée des
guadeloupéens
ils vont se battre sur la question dhabi
cheikh ils vont aussi d'une certaine
manière revendiquer la reconnaissance
identitaire avec le fameux slogan payer
1,7 à nous pays à ces pressions mais ils
vont complètement gober les aspect
fondamental
précisément qui était l'un des aspects
qui était précisément celui de la lutte
contre le colon qu'on appelait à
l'époque le colonialisme alors la grogne
est venu en martinique et des
travailleurs des syndicats
la classe politique elle absente dépassé
comme d'habitude elle ne réagit pas elle
subit en tout cas elle rentre dans la
danse plutôt tardivement à fort de
france
c'est parfaitement lu vu ll est dépassé
a confronté il est vrai aussi que
personne ne s'y attendrait il n'y avait
pas en martinique ont très mal à bois
d'où vient 6 il n'y a pas il n'y avait
pas eu de 6 avant coureurs les syndicats
étaient en ordre dispersé et puis
brutalement il décide finalement de se
rencontrer un peu à la va vite et à la
surprise générale la mayonnaise prend au
début on pense que c'est précisément une
sorte de deux coups de chaleur de
mauvaise humeur qui passera comme
d'habitude on assiège les stations
services mais ça c'est habituel et puis
au fur et à mesure où s'aperçoit que le
mal est plus profond
les gens par milliers et parmi les et ça
effectivement sites historiques les gens
par milliers par milliers pendant 38
jours c'est pas rien quand même un n'est
pas rien ceux-ci mobilis battent le pavé
avec évidemment un slogan phare un peu
répétitif en paya c'est à nous payer à
ses pattes ayo et puis on voit surtout
dur alors par conséquent le pays est
bloqué quasiment partout on s'aperçoit
ya pas une vie à fort-de-france et puis
à ailleurs il ya une vie à
fort-de-france ailleurs évidemment
ailleurs les gens sont moins mobilisés
mais beaucoup des soldats forme ferait
beaucoup les soldes à fort de france
et comme l'a dit une dame koné arrivé
tout à l'heure évidemment il s'amarrera
plus le temps de robert les gens de la
campagne vise yeux parce qu'évidemment
ils ont ils ont de quoi manger
alors que ceux de la ville sont en panne
car tous les supermarchés sont fermés et
on remet en cause et là c'est une
revendication politique qui
n'apparaissait pas au début l'heureux de
l'import export et des grands patrons
alors la fierté de participer à quelque
chose qui fait peuple qui rassemble
surtout à travers cette manifestation
jean claude on a ouvert la boîte de
pandore tout le monde a des
revendications dans toutes les branches
professionnelles dans tous les secteurs
tout y passe
et on se rend compte que finalement pas
ni problème mathématique tab et ce n'est
qu'une légende finalement non je crois
que c'est un peu plus complexe que ça je
crois que les gens en réalité touche du
loup à cette occasion les difficultés du
quotidien
mais il faut aussi souligner le rôle
particulier fonctionnaires qui pour la
plupart se mettent en grève
mais en réalité les gens se je crois
qu'il ya un malentendu il ya un
malentendu ce que finalement les
politiques puissent par croire c'est
qu'on lui la france est découvert dans
français nicolas sarkozy ils croient que
nous sommes en présence de ce qu'ils
vont appeler une crise sociétale par
conséquent que ces îles que derrière la
revendication du quotidien du pouvoir
d'achat il ya une crise identitaire et
la volonté par conséquent de voir
reconnu son identité
paya cet anneau payez pas ta yo mais en
réalité les genres certainement sont
soucieux du cela mais en même temps ils
ne veulent pas que fondamentalement les
choses changent
nous sommes en phase ce qu'on peut
appeler le paradoxe du refus et de la
lésion leur refus c'est quoi le refus
c'est là le fait qu'on ne veut plus qu'à
notre identité soigner on veut pouvoir
danser le beller côte d'ivoire par les
nounous et inique et en même temps il y
à l'adhésion au système
on ne veut pas à changer de ne pas du
tout changer le paradigme nous les mois
je faire une fois cela mais bien joué
monsieur et c'est pour cela que
finalement pense à régler la crise
sociétale
nicolas sarkozy président de la
république organise une grand-messe
qu'on appelle les états généraux
alors ok du succès à la hauteur de la
contestation à la hauteur de la
contestation dans sa dimension
identitaire il y avait le tavana que les
cultures que j'ai eu l'honneur de l'un
d'eux président et où un tas de choses
ont été dites notamment la place des
békés par exemple dans notre société y
avait des choses très très importantes
qui ont été dites mais lorsque tir
ensemble croyait-il la conclusion de
tout cela le président de l'afd libre de
l'accord on va faire une consultation
populaire
une consultation populaire avec la
possibilité le mot n'est pas prononcé
mais lisez présente d'opter pour
l'autonomie la classe politique
applaudie elle est contente elle croit
qu'elle a gagné et elle prend une baffe
il gifle
ouais une gifle terrible parce que
précisément il ya une différence de
niveau
on over rester français ouais on veut
rester frais ça c'est le peuple c'est le
lieu que le développeur le temps de me
fait peur mais on veut aussi être
martiniquais et c'est ce qui s'est passé
deux mois
doit-on faire un parallèle avec ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en france avec les
gilet jaune et puis ce grand débat
national du d'emmanuel macron vu comme
une façon de discuter avec la population
qui affiche ses souffrances écoutez moi
ce qui me frappe c'est que le point de
départ des gilets jaunes c'est pouvoir
d'achat en france en martinique or il
semble que ces jours ci les gens se
mettent un peu en mouvement mais jusqu'à
présent observé que les gilet jaune ici
ont pas pris du tout il a eu deux
manifestations n'a que les ordres 2une
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide
je crois que y est cela mais il ya aussi
le fait que comment dire les difficultés
de pouvoir d'achat sont vécues ici mais
avec une certaine distanciation sebaï la
france nous ici en vue difficilement
mais on vit quand même on va en
croisière rouler les champions ça coûte
moins cher de leur choisir plutôt que de
pronos billets d'avion points en france
ou bien même poêle en guadeloupe que 300
jusqu'à 350 euros mais parce qu'elle est
en colère c'est chic c'est bien ça va
vite ça coûte cher ce que j'ai à dire
c'est qu'on a pris les habitudes de
consommation terrible est que les
caddies l'homme aussi il faut que la vie
fait que c'est moi qui fais les courses
et par conséquent je vois les caddies
des autres je suis censé avoir vu à peu
près convenable et bien des gens qui à
la date apparemment n'ont pas le même
niveau de vie comme les caddies pleins
cologna avec dvd délivrent des produits
plus chers que sur la droite jean-claude
attention vous faire taper sur les
doigts mais c'est vrai que la vie est
toujours aussi cher les abonnements
téléphone internet doit parler du prix
du billet d'avion les pièces automobiles
les prix en grande surface on n'a pas
envie de dire on a envie de dire que
rien n'a changé
rien n'a changé on s'en accommode en
sonaca mal parce que par ailleurs il ya
toute une série de choses l'on peut
faire je reprends l'exemple des deux
lacs de l'hyperconsommation on peut
continuer à hyper consommer
souvenez-vous que par exemple récemment
on nous indiquait qu avec la guadeloupe
nous étions les champions de la
consommation de champagne c'était eux
qui permet de stocker ne soit pas trop
la martinique est concernée aussi alors
ce que je veux dire en réalité c'est que
la vie et du réveil est difficile mais
malgré tout on peut continuer à vivre
l'immatriculation des voitures
augmentent d'année en année
tout cela fait qu s'accommode du système
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui la grande
différence
en dix ans la grande différence c'est
quoi c'est que précisément le malaise
identitaire s'est dissipée aujourd'hui
vous avez vu le débat vous avez entendu
les débats sur l'hymne sur le drapeau
sur rouge-vert-noir la met d'accord mais
fois-ci bout il ya débat il ya dix ans y
avait pas d bah ouais c'est ça c'est ça
la bonne difficulté aujourd'hui aux
romantiques aujourd'hui on parle pour
amener votre vie vous ne menez plus
grâce aux cours de danse classique vous
l'emmenait au sermac ou dans un lieu de
cette nature pour qu'il apprenne à jouer
autant boréaux il ya plus de
restrictions là-dessus d'accord par
conséquent à partir du moment où cette
dimension-là est réglé eh bien on
s'accommode du reste de temps que le
reste est pas si mal que ça et alors
pour parvenir au grand débat alors le
grand débat grand débat c'est quoi le
grand débat on a vu des hommes
politiques tout à fait respectable mais
tu as un peu pris les choses par le papa
par le petit bout mais nous avons vu ils
n'ont pas vu leur population pour les
dire aux présidents secrétaires des
martiniquais ils ont juste pris nos
billets d'avion c'est sûr
une promesse et par conséquent ils ont
re poser les questions qu'ils avaient
déjà posé peu de moi bon ce qu'il oublie
de dire c'est que le président ait
public était venu en martinique
trois mois avant et que effectivement
toutes ces revendications très très très
propre très particulières avaient été
portées que le président avait cédé sur
certaines choses
tiens il avait bien compris lui que
l'identité c'est un problème et il avait
reconnu que les cas le serpent il
fallait s'en séparer sur le reste il a
tenu les propos assez alambiqué et
personnes la deûle a souligné oui ou non
tous les rapports fait régulièrement sur
la situation toutes les préconisations
toutes les études ça sert à quelque
chose finalement
oui ou non oui oui merci beaucoup je
plaide williams professeur émérite et
observateur de la vie contemporaine on
sait que vous faites c'est vous qui
allez faire les courses c'est votre jour
des soldes